So I really hate that I was right about this,
but I was right about this.
Donald Trump and his FDA chairman, Steven
Hahn, dramatically and irresponsibly overhyped
and oversold their announcement about convalescent
plasma as a corona virus treatment.
And Stephen Hahn is now admitting it.
And, of course, it really shouldn't surprise
any of us because they've been overhyping
everything all along, going all the way back
to hydroxy chloroquine months ago.
Now, I told you when Donald Trump held this
completely belligerent, unhinged event on
Sunday, promoted on Saturday as a huge announcement
about Corona virus treatment.
The announcement was the FDA has issued an
emergency use authorization for convalescent
plasma.
This was suspicious.
Convalescent plasma is a procedure.
It's a direct transfusion of plasma from people
who have recovered from corona virus.
The idea being that transfusing their plasma
into people suffering from the virus could
be an effective treatment.
Now, the reason that it was suspicious from
the get go was because there was nothing new
about convalescent plasma.
So Donald Trump making a big announcement
and trying to pat himself on the back as if
this is an achievement for him or for his
administration.
That didn't make sense.
And that was where I started to think there's
something a little bit fishy going on here.
And if you've been following Corona virus
for months, the way we have, you would know
that convalescent plasma transfusions have
been a potential treatment for a corona virus
for months around the world.
I have relatives in Argentina who have coronavirus.
And six weeks ago, the possibility of giving
them convalescent plasma, plasma transfusion
if they became sicker was a possibility.
It has nothing to do with Donald Trump.
And so really, the announcement was the FDA
is issuing an emergency youth use authorization.
The announcement was not really.
We now can do this thing called convalescent
plasma transfusions.
It was we're going to change the for the infrastructure
from being able to do the convalescent plasma
within a randomized controlled trial to doing
it under an emergency use authorization.
And that did not seem like a particularly
good idea for the reasons I told you on Sunday
and on Monday, including that it may start
to be given to patients who are less sick
and don't actually need something because
they would recover naturally.
And there are risks, including lung injury
and other potential problems with these convalescent
plasma transfusions.
Also giving when you have an RC t, a randomly
controlled, randomized controlled trial.
You're really zeroing out confounding factors
to try to focus in on what was the effect
of the convalescent plasma.
And when you do an EU way and you start giving
the treatment to more people, including people
who were going to recover any way it can falsely
or deceptively, incorrectly make the treatment
seem more effective than it is.
Okay.
I told you all of that on Monday.
Well, Steven Hahn, the FDA director, Steven
Hahn, has now conceded that, yes, it's true,
he exaggerated the effectiveness of the treatment
on Sunday.
He doesn't even try to hide it.
He tweeted at the end of a series of tweets,
quote, I have been criticized for remarks
I made Sunday night about the benefits of
convalescent plasma.
The criticism is entirely justified.
What I should have said better is that the
data show a relative risk reduction and not
an absolute risk reduction.
This was totally obvious all along.
And Trump's Sunday stunt was merely a stunt
to try to take credit for something that no
one has nothing to do with him whatsoever
anyway.
And number two, shock is not the miracle that
they claim it is now.
I guess.
OK.
Let me do this, hon.
Also went into some garbage math on Sunday.
On Sunday, Hans said the drug appears kont
or convalescent plasma treatment appears to
lower mortality by 35 percent.
So he said for every hundred people who get
the virus, it saves 35 people.
That's insane.
Okay.
Now I has.
The reason I'm hesitating is the math is so
stupid that I don't know if it's patronizing
to even do this, but I think it's worth putting
on the record.
The death rate of corona virus appears to
be about zero point eight percent.
If you account for, you know, all, all, all,
all cases, not a case fatality rate, but a
death rate, let's call it one percent.
What that means is that for every hundred
people who get corona virus, you would expect
one to die, one percent death rate.
So if convalescent plasma reduces mortality
by 35 percent.
If a thousand people get the virus, you would
expect that 10 would die one percent.
And convalescent plasma would potentially
save three or four people.
Right.
If it's 35 percent.
It's three point five people per thousand
that it would save based on a one percent
mortality rate.
Now, I want to be really clear if that's true.
That's important.
That's significant.
That's not nothing.
Those numbers are shaky and it's not clear
that that's what it is.
But the press release from the FDA containing
these claims was clearly a propaganda document
written by the White House.
And when, hon, maybe he misstated and said
from every hundred people that get it, this
saves 35 from every hundred people that get
it.
You only expect one to die.
So how could it save 35 when you only expect
one to die?
The tragic thing is and if people get why
this math is garbage, I apologize for going
through that.
The tragic thing is that for many of us, maybe
it's obvious, but so many people are still
falling for this stuff.
And that's that's the real tragedy here.
You know, dexamethasone tested globally, available
globally for months.
Donald Trump takes credit for it as one of
the therapeutics that his administration has
moved forward.
They haven't done a damn thing about it.
Room desk, severe tested globally, available
globally for months, part of randomized controlled
trials all over the country.
Trump tries to take credit if it's something
that his administration did.
Dozens of vaccines under development.
Many aren't.
Even American companies developing the vaccines.
We.
The vaccine that ends up being the vaccine
might end up being from Oxford University
in the UK. Trump takes credit in advance.
Under his operation, warp speed.
They're lying all the time.
And what I fear is that it will work.
I still continue to think it is very likely
that we get an announcement about we've got
a vaccine.
It's good to go around October 15th.
Won't be available right away.
Not too many people.
And Donald Trump will take credit and it'll
shift one or two percent of the vote and that'll
get him reelected.
This fundamentally is going to be a situation
that is dealt with by doctors and by public
health in the United States and around the
world.
And it's going to be dealt with despite Donald
Trump, not thanks to him and Trump trying
to claim heroic credit by saying we funded
production of vaccine doses in advance.
That's great.
Multiple countries are doing that.
Any sane leader would do that.
It would be an injustice not to do that, to
start producing vaccine doses in advance.
Common tactic has nothing to do with Trump.
Republicans and Trump are trying to create
the illusion that their leadership has saved
the day.
In reality, there hasn't been leadership.
And as far as having to walk back, you know,
the plasma stuff, the damage is already done.
Way more people see the headline than see
the correction.
This is the M.O. of the Trump administration.
You put out some hyperbole upfront.
People see it.
They integrate it later.
You correct it.
Stephen Horne says, you know, I did oversell
it a little bit.
Very few people see it and it's too late anyway.
It's typical.
It's a common strategy and it's exactly what
they're doing.